breaking news hierbei bild denn laut
medienberichten der bbc soll
großbritanniens premierminister boris
johnson jetzt zurücktreten sie sehen
hier schon das bild der downing street
ja das ist ein rücktritt der war mehr
als abzusehenden innerhalb von nur zwei
tagen waren schon aus einem anti boris
protest sozusagen mehr als 50
abgeordnete aus seinen eigenen reihen
zurück getreten und es wurden ständig
mehr gehen wir nach london zu an
strickler art bisher sind es nur
medienberichte aber wie sicher ist der
rücktritt von boris johnson jetzt nur
dieser rücktritt ist sicher und ich muss
sagen hier in großbritannien heute
morgen über das kein mehr koste als
johnson hat ja immer den beinamen tesla
boris weil wohl alle krisen anscheinend
an ihm einfach abperlen damit ist es
jetzt endgültig vorbei vor wenigen
minuten hat auch ein sprecher aus der
downing street und das ist wirklich
ernst zu nehmen bestätigt der
premierminister wird gehen er wird
ziemlich schnell gehen wir rechnen noch
damit dass er heute vor dieser tür die
wir hier im bild sehen vor diesem
berühmten nummer 10 downing street
treten wird und sagen dieser rücktritt
offiziell bekanntgeben wird das war hat
ja lange gedauert muss man sagen krise
nach krise kam und immer wieder hat er
sich geweigert zurückzutreten noch heute
morgen hat boris johnson ist das gesagt
man müsste ihn schon mit einem und jetzt
zieht hier ich mer mal flammenwerfer aus
der nummer 10 downing street vertreiben
bisher zurück tritt jetzt hat er aber
doch einsicht gezeigt und ich höre aus
der tory partie dass spätestens bis
oktober ein neuer partei führe und damit
auch an neuer premierminister für dieses
land für großbritannien gefunden sein
soll wird es dann also weitergehen wenn
du jetzt sagst bis oktober soll jemand
neues team gefunden werden eben ein
neuer premierminister wann bis wann ist
bausch tanzen dann noch im amt bzw wird
das alles dann direkt heute quasi ein
schlussstrich gezogen haben
vermutlich wird heute noch ein
schlussstrich gezogen vermutlich wird
ein deputy also ein stellvertretender
regierungschef ernannt werden wer das
ist ist bislang unklar ich höre zum
beispiel dass die aus ministerin lässt
was gute karten haben soll dieses rennen
zumindest temporär die
regierungsgeschäfte in großbritannien zu
übernehmen damit hätten wir zum dritten
mal in diesem jahr eine frau die dieses
land führt das wird also alles ziemlich
relativ schnell gehen denn das ganze
land ist sich in einem sicher dieser
premierminister premierminister peinlich
der muss so schnell wie möglich weg
premierminister peinlich sagst du
vielleicht kannst du mit uns noch mal
die letzten tage rekapitulieren der
rücktritt wenn er denn jetzt kommt er
hat sich ja mehr als angekündigt
das ist richtig der rücklicht hat sich
seit lange angekündigt boris becker hat
er
hatte immer wieder skandale hingelegt
deswegen im vergangenen jahr weihnachten
an da hat der illegale partys abgehalten
in der downing street von denen es dann
auch bilder gab während das land im
harten locker und war und dann folgt der
skandal auf skandal unter anderem hat er
dann mal zwischendurch kurz das
parlament beurlaubt musste dann vom
höchsten gerichtshof hier in
großbritannien zurück gefunden werden
der das größte höchste gericht hat
gesagt diese beurlaubung des parlaments
sei rechtswidrig das war also auch
einziger klub muss man sagen und jetzt
das letzte der jüngste skandal der ihn
dann letztlich doch zum verhängnis wurde
er wusste dass ein chor partei
mitarbeiter und ein minister den er
selbst ernannt hat eine vorgeschichte
hat für sexuelle übergriffe auf
kolleginnen und kollegen das hat er
immer wieder bestritten dass er das
musste jetzt gab es wieder einen solchen
vorfall ressourcen hat ganz
offensichtlich vor dem parlament gelogen
hat gesagt er habe nichts davon gewusst
dann muss der zurückrudern hat gesagt er
habe doch was davon gewusst hat dass nur
vergessen und wenn eines im britischen
unterhaus abgeordneten gar nicht mögen
dann ist das bildung zu werden und eine
letzte frage noch schneller dich wie
beliebt war war es sonst jetzt zuletzt
noch im land
nun im land feiern nicht mehr sonderlich
beliebt er die letzten jüngsten
kommunalwahlen haben die tories krachend
verloren das deutet darauf hin dass auch
innerhalb der bevölkerung die zustimmung
zu krimis oder peinlich mittlerweile auf
einem tiefpunkt ist an strickler ganz
herzlichen dank an dich und wir sehen
hier immer noch das live-bild der
downing street sobald sich da was tut
sind wir natürlich für sie da sprechen
wir weiter über den möglichen rücktritt
über denen ja so ziemlich sicheren
rücktritt vom rücktritt von boris
johnson bei uns im studio albert link
aber wir die bild wir hatten ihn
bezeichnet als pattex premierminister
aso hin den man wirklich sozusagen von
seinem stuhl kratzen muss
die regierung war die kann man die als
geisterschiff bezeichnen naja ist
tatsächlich so gewesen dass die
rücktritte ja minütlich waren am ende
hat eindeutig verpasst den richtigen
moment für seinen rücktritt zu finden er
hätte gestern zurücktreten müssen er hat
stattdessen noch einen seiner engsten
weggefährten gefeuert ihn auch noch von
seinen sprechern als schlange darstellen
lassen er hat wie manche kommentatoren
auch gesagt haben die realität
offensichtlich verloren denn es war
offensichtlich dass er weder im
parlament noch in der bevölkerung noch
rückhalt hatte und selbst die sun die
boulevardzeitung die ihm am längsten und
am stärksten den rücken gestärkt hat und
immer hinter ihm gestanden hat hat heute
morgen geschrieben er soll in würde
gehen und das ist jetzt schon der alle
aller allerletzte moment um das zu tun
um nicht zu sagen es ist eigentlich zu
spät es ist eigentlich eine schande dass
er zu diesem rücktritt so gedrängt
werden musste und nicht von sich aus die
zeichen der zeit erkannt hat
können wir das noch einmal zusammen
verwundert bzw wenn man jetzt eben die
englische politik die britische politik
eben nicht die ganze zeit im blick dass
ein premierminister daneben dazu
aufgefordert wird wirklich jetzt zu
gehen von ganz unterschiedlichen
menschen einmal von den medien von der
eigenen partei und so weiter das ist ja
wirklich was wo man hinkommt wo man
hinhören muss warum das hat der kollege
eben schon sehr richtig gesagt in london
es gibt bei den engländern ein größeres
eine größere bereitschaft als bei uns
dinge zu verzeihen boris johnson hatte
immer eine art von bonus ich habe
gestern noch mit unserem experten von
der london school of economics
gesprochen der gesagt hat in england
sagt man jede katze hat mein leben boris
johnson hatte schon 13 ihm ist alles
verziehen worden mit ausnahme
seines ersten großen skandal ist denn
schon an den rand des rücktritts
gebracht hat nämlich seine corona partys
da geht es ja nicht darum dass man ihm
nicht könnte dass er zwei gläser wein
getrunken hat sondern es geht darum dass
er seine eigenen regeln ja seinen
landsleuten auferlegt hat einfach
bewusst gebrochen hat und dabei zum
ersten mal in großem maße die
öffentlichkeit belogen hat die die
wahrheit kam häppchenweise ans licht es
wäre eigentlich ich glaube in jedem
anderen land und mit jedem anderen
premier schon der moment gewesen was
vorbei ist dass er jetzt noch mal
dieselbe taktik welt und die
öffentlichkeit das parlament
dermaßen dreist belegt mit einer
personalentscheidung die er getroffen
hat mit wissen
was die problematik der sexuellen
übergriffe betrifft und das im
nachhinein ans licht kommt das müsste
eigentlich
selbst boris johnson klar gewesen sein
dass er damit nicht noch mal durchkommt
es gab viele skandale vorher viele davon
sind ihm verziehen worden vergessen wenn
ich dass der exit für den er maßgeblich
stand auch auf einer großen lüge basiert
hat nämlich die dass die die briten
jährlich wöchentlich 350 millionen pfund
an die eu zu überweisen müssen und dass
dieses geld doch besser in der
gesundheitsvorsorge in der öffentlichen
besser aufgehoben werden damit ging es
los die karriere begann der große
aufstieg begann mit einer großen lüge
und nun endet diese karriere auch mit
einer lüge hat sich das auch immer gar
nicht vorstellen dass sie dann einfach
so lügen und denken dass sie damit
durchkommen also gut der rücktritt ist
es dann sozusagen auch das ende einer
politischen karriere in jederlei
hinsicht
das bleibt abzuwarten er hat boris
johnson ist privat ja immer wieder auf
die beine gekommen nach seinen eskapaden
mit seinem privatleben er ist er hat
sicherlich freunde im politischen
betrieb er ist sicherlich
ein wichtiger player gewesen jetzt was
die unterstützung der ukraine anbelangt
man darf nicht vergessen das ist ja für
uns auch eine schlechte nachricht er war
sozusagen da derjenige der die
verantwortung als erster übernommen hat
die unterstützung klar signalisiert hat
sicherlich der andere länder mitgezogen
hat was seine aufgabe seine funktion
sein wird wissen wir alle nicht hat sehr
gut immer davon gelebt zu schreiben
bücher zu schreiben zeitungsartikel zu
schreiben kolumnist zu sein
all das steht in den sternen ich bin mir
sicher er wird nicht am hungertuch nagen
aber die politische karriere ist zu ende
vielen dank für deine analyse hier boris
sonst tritt zurück das heißt in
großbritannien bei jones der britische
premier boris sonst in tritt zurück wir
sehen hier im splitscreen immer noch das
bild von der tür auf die vor dr einig in
den nächsten stunden treten wird und
dann auch noch mal selber eben seinen
rücktritt verkünden wird wir werden dann
natürlich live in gehen sie verpassen
bei uns hierbei bild live nichts zu dem
rücktritt von boris johnson dort in
großbritannien